what is up everybody it's warren welcome
back to the cosmic wonder real quick no
spoilers in this video i will not be
spoiling anything about spider-man
knowing home but today is the day
some people saw it yesterday i
acknowledged that i think the uk saw it
yesterday and i acknowledge that some
people won't be seeing it for maybe
another month which i'm really sorry
about but for most of the world
today is the opening day for spider-man
no way home and i just wanted to take
this opportunity to say thank you all so
much for this journey the road to
spider-man knowing home has been so fun
it's been a blast for me i hope it's
been a blast for you i've loved talking
to everybody on instagram on twitter and
the comments on my youtube videos i love
seeing everybody's reactions on
instagram and twitter it's just been so
much fun this past year
uh talking about no way home
the rumors the leaks everything leading
up to this movie it's been such
it was such an amazing time and it's all
thanks to you all and i just wanted to
kind of do this candid video here of me
saying thank you because once you see
this movie
you'll be blown away i was blown away i
was fortunate enough again because of
you all to get invited by sony to the
world premiere so i saw it a couple days
ago
and i'm about to go see it right now for
the second time so i wanted to take this
opportunity and just say
i know you're gonna love this movie
because you've been with me on this
journey the whole entire time
i know you're going to love this movie
and it was so much fun i hope you all
had fun too because i i i had so much
fun this was the time of my life talking
about spider-man way home
and it's it's it's exciting that it's
finally here and it's sad that it's here
um
but you know i thought a lot this is not
this definitely is not the end of the
journey this was the road to spider-man
no way home and it was so much fun and
yes
we've reached it but the journey is not
over there's still a lot more coming and
we're fans right i know we all love
spider-man a lot of us love spider-man
more than some other characters i
totally get that but we're still fans of
marvel the mcu superheroes and you'll
see what's coming up
and i i believe that the journey has
only just begun and we're going to have
more spider-man there's going to be more
spider-man in the mcu right tom holland
looks like he's doing another one for
sure and even after him we'll have
another one it could be one of you all
watching these videos right now you know
we never know what's going to happen
spider woman they're all coming could be
one of y'all watching right now who
knows there's a lot ahead of us
and this was just so much fun and you
all have been the best and it's because
of you
that i've
done this that i've
talked about spider-man so much because
it was fun and everybody enjoyed it and
not gonna lie i was like oh man maybe
i'm talking about spider-man too much
but it was really fun for me and it
seemed to be fun for y'all so i just
kept doing it because
do what you love right i'm fortunate
enough to be able to do what i love and
i'm glad that it can make some people
happy i'm glad that a lot of people
are happy with no way home to me
personally it is now my favorite
superhero movie um of all time to me it
does surpass in-game and it does surpass
infinity war which is hard and it's not
gonna be that way for everybody but
you know what i i really love spider-man
and i think this movie was the perfect
spider-man movie
because they truly captured who
spider-man and peter parker are i think
they really captured that in this movie
and it was just an emotional
rollercoaster and to me that that it
really made it there's a lot of parts
that i want to talk about once you know
i do like a spoiler free or i'm sorry
once i do a spoiler talk there's things
that i want to talk about i think
that'll probably come out tomorrow
so i'll save my thoughts till then
so you all can watch the movie and i
hope everyone loves it let me know what
you think if you've already seen it in
the comments uh if you haven't seen it
avoid the comments because there's
probably going to be spoilers in it but
about to go watch for the second time in
literally one hour from now so
thank you thank you all
seriously
thank you
without you guys i
i want to be here but i'm glad i'm here
i'm glad we went through this together
so
until next time
i'll catch y'all later love you all 3000
woof